in the last video we talked a little bit
about what inflation is in the consumer
price index and so i thought i would
actually show you data and maybe point
out a few interesting things right over
here so this right over here is the
monthly press release versus the table
from the monthly press release issued by
the bureau of labor statistics and this
is table a which is really a summary of
all of the important things it's the
percent changes in cpi for all urban
consumers the cpi-u and they do it for
non-or urban consumers and all the rest
but the cpi that is quoted is the one
for urban consumers the u.s city average
and what i always find is that the
details are much more interesting than
what you hear just on the news when
people say oh the cpi changed by point
you know point five percent and one
thing i do want to point out and this is
true of the cpi this is true of all
government statistics and frankly this
is true of any report that any company
gives you it's very important to keep in
mind whether they're giving a sequential
change or whether they're giving a
year-over-year change so for example
they might there might be a press
release there might be a press release
like this one and the text of it or
maybe the headline number when you look
at the your local newspaper your news
report will say look in june 2011
inflation on all items on the entire
basket of good went
basket of goods went down by point two
percent and you might say oh wow look
there's no inflation in flack prices are
going down this would be minor deflation
but it's important to realize that this
is only the seasonally adjusted prices
from may to june
from may to june and when i talk about
seasonally adjusted and that
traditionally maybe people use a
different amount of energy a different
amount of gasoline from may to june and
they they try to factor that in when
they compare the basket of good the
price of the basket of good from may to
june so that's what they talk about
seasonally adjusting but if you look
over here the prices went down from may
to june according to according to
adjusting it for the season but the
year-over-year changes are still up
if you compare june 2011 to june 2010 it
is still up by 3.6 percent and in
general the monthly things are going to
be a little bit more volatile obviously
you have the seasonal adjustments you
have other short-term factors that might
change it but the year-over-year one is
a is a is a stronger signal for what is
actually happening for inflation
although someone might want to pay
attention to the monthly one because
that's obviously giving you kind of the
most up-to-date of what's happening now
and what you'll often see is they'll
give an inflation number for everything
and then they'll subtract out actually
food and energy so this is all items
less food less food and energy and
that's because food and energy they
represent a good bit of the basket but
they're very very volatile you can see
it right here in this report year over
year energy
energy
has gone up
double digits 20 percent for for
for energy generally if you look at fuel
oil 35.6 percent at least on this report
has been coming down more recently but
year over year it's been up a huge
amount and so that's actually the main
driving factor for this 3.6 percent if
you take food and energy out of the
equation if you compare the basket of
goods minus that inflation was only up
1.6 it's interesting even within that
you can look at which which parts of the
economy or which products and services
are getting a lot more expensive and
which ones are getting cheaper it's
actually interesting that used cars and
trucks are up 5.1 percent that seems
like a pretty strong price increase for
for used for used things